beinahe wäre markus söder
kanzlerkandidat der union geworden jetzt
ist er als csu vorsitzender in berlin in
der opposition und in bayern kämpft er
als ministerpräsident mit schwachen
beliebtheitswerten in beiden rollen
teilte kräftig aus gegen die
energiepolitik der bundesregierung doch
wie steht es um seine eigene
energiebilanz und wie geht er um mit
schwindenden zustimmungswerten in bayern
darüber rede ich heute mit markus söder
hier in nürnberg herzlich willkommen zum
zdf sommerinterview
[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen beim zdf
sommerinterview in nürnberg wir haben
sie schon vier mal hier in nürnberg
getroffen und im letzten jahr waren wir
bei ihnen im stadion beim 1 fc nürnberg
bei ihrem herzensklub heute gibt es auch
wieder eine gelegenheit darüber zu reden
der hat nämlich gestern verloren 0 2 und
ich wüsste gerne von ihnen weil es eben
ihr klub ist haben sie eigentlich für
die mannschaft einen tipp für den umgang
mit niederlagen
also in nürnberg ist man was den klub
trifft es über all die jahrzehnte ist er
gewöhnt wenn man zu erfolgreich ist ist
man dann eher schon unsicher damit
bricht zusammen muss ich war mal jahre
daran aufsichtsrat da war man mal
pokalsieger
das ist wir können sind willens auf die
park ganz großen momente und hoffen dass
wir sonst keine zeit kommen was ist
positive schauen knüpft vielleicht ganz
gut an weil ich würde gerne mit ihnen
auch über fehlerkultur sprechen ich habe
in der vorbereitung auf dieses interview
natürlich viel gelesen auch von ihnen
interviews gelesen oder fällt eine sache
auf sie reden nicht gerne über eigene
fehler jetzt sind wir hier in nürnberg
im kreuzgang des germanischen
nationalmuseums direkt vor dem christus
und sie sind gläubiger christ ich bau
dir mir mal eine frage aus der bibel der
mich aus der bergpredigt die da lautet
warum siehst du den splitter im auge
deines bruders aber den balken in deinem
eigenen augen siehst du nicht mit
klavier sehen alle balken wir sehen alle
später aber wir sollten auch über
diejenigen reden die jetzt sozusagen die
hauptverantwortung haben und die darüber
entscheiden ob aus einem kleinen balken
ein ganzer wald wird der ernsteren am
ende beschwört sie reden über den splitt
wir mal setzte das gespräch geräten über
alles wirklich vorschlagen machen wir
gerne an unseren äckern
[Musik]
wir waren beim thema umgang mit fehlern
und ich würde ganz gerne mit einem
fehler beginnen den ich gemacht habe ich
habe sie nämlich vor ein paar wochen
falsch wiedergegeben da hatte ich grob
zusammengefasst dass sie im notfall auch
dafür seien noch mal über gas aus nord
stream zwei zu verhandeln das tun sie
nicht und das tun sie auch jetzt in
dieser angespannten situation nicht
gestern nochmal rekord strompreise warum
nicht ich glaube das löst nicht das
problem in meinen putin betreibt mit uns
ein endspiel
und die frage ist ob wir auf dieses
spiel richtig vorbereiten ich mache mir
ein bisschen sorgen ob die gesamte
strategie aufgeht dass wirksamer werden
wahrscheinlich waffen zu liefern da tun
wir uns schwer wird ja auch sehr
angemahnt von unseren verbündeten beim
thema energie wird zahlen jetzt im
moment praktisch mehr geld nach russland
überweisen wie als wir vorher hatten und
es besteht schon die gefahr dass bei uns
erhebliche verwerfungen probleme drohen
die preise wie sie richtig sagen
explodieren die versorgungslage wird
schwer ersatz kommt keiner trotzdem auf
das spiel von putin ein kind geht nicht
die aufgabe muss jetzt sein ersatz zu
finden und die bisherigen reisen die
gemacht wurden katar norwegen kanada
haben bislang keinen ersatz gebracht das
thema ersatz finden bereitet gerade in
bayern große schwierigkeiten der
allgemeine befund der mann den man jetzt
immer wieder hört lautet bayern hat die
energiewende verschlafen ihre
landtagspräsidentin ilse aigner hat
gerade gesagt der strom engpass von nord
nach süd der sei auch selbstverschuldet
von ihnen hört man diese selbstkritik
nicht warum nicht weil es so nicht
stimmt als wir liegen bei den
erneuerbaren energien gesamt umgerechnet
auf platz 23 auf platz eins bei der
grundlastfähigkeit was ja das wichtigste
erneuerbaren energien absolut klar von
werden zum beispiel mehr photovoltaik
als nordrhein westfalen baden
württemberg und rheinland pfalz zusammen
auf fläche und personen umgelegt nicht
das ist ja jetzt auch schon öfter aber
diese umrechnung winter mal komisch also
auch flächen personen umgerechnet china
nur auf platz 64 der wirtschaftsleistung
oder auf personen umgerechnet wert beim
oder bei den letzten olympischen spielen
nummer eins gewesen ist absurd bayern
leiste den größten anteil mit an
erneuerbaren energien in deutschland das
ist einfach fakt und zu den stromtrassen
da haben sie recht
es ist seit vielen jahren in ganz
deutschland problem die beiden großen
fassen um die es geht südlich und
südöstlich werden von der
bundesnetzagentur geplant nicht von
bayern aber das ist bislang nicht viel
passiert haben entschieden zusammen mit
horst seehofer dagegen gearbeitet als
minister haben sie auch als heimat
minister war das damals 2015 gezielt den
breitflächigen ausbau von stromtrassen
durch landesrecht noch einmal erschwert
und haben eben auch dafür besorgt man
sich wahlweise flächen vor allem flächen
eingeschränkt haben auf denen gebaut
werden darf und sie haben auch dafür
gesorgt dass diese großen trasse
unterirdisch gebaut werden was das ganze
sehr stark verzögert hat darin sehen sie
auch nach rückblickend ein fehler der
erste des gemacht oder sigmar gabriel
selbst als wir damals zuständige
minister ganz deutschland wollten sie
die wahrheit ist doch wenn wir etwas
voranbringen wollen bis es mit den
bürgern machen nicht gegen wenn sie sich
mal vor ort anschauen am meisten dagegen
fort sind grüne gruppen bei uns noch
freie wählergruppen und deswegen war die
entscheidung unterirdisch zu verlegen
eine deutsche keine bayerische
entscheidung ich halte ich für richtig
aber jetzt muss er mehr gemacht werden
wir haben unser personal deutlich
verstärkt der bund hat ist bislang nicht
getan das ist eine aufgabe für alle und
noch einmal woanders geht es auch nicht
schneller sie hat es gerade angesprochen
sie schauen darauf wie die bürgerinnen
und bürger vor ort reagieren da könnten
sie ja als landesregierung und als
csu-vorsitzender auch dagegenhalten und
sagen passt mal auf das ist jetzt nötig
es gibt große kritik an ihnen weil sie
immer den einfachsten weg gehen habe ich
einmal gelesen den weg des geringsten
widerstandes da wo eben am wenigsten
protest droht werden immer mal als
beispiel die akw verlängerungen die sie
ja jetzt wieder so groß diskutieren 2011
hatten die menschen angst vor dem
atomunfall
damals haben sie als minister mit
rücktritt gedroht für den fall dass die
akw über 2022 hinaus verlängert werden
heute haben die menschen angst vor dem
stromausfall und sie sind für die
verlängerung welche diese entscheidungen
haben sie denn ohne blick auf die
allgemeine stimmung tragen beide sind
richtig gewesen die grundsätzliche frage
nach der damaligen frage der
beherrschbarkeit der atomenergie
langfristig auszusteigen war doch
allgemeiner deutscher konzerns ich habe
da niemand gesehen der etwas anders
gesagt hat jetzt geht es doch um die
frage wie man eine krise durch kommen
kein mensch versteht warum seiten
monaten die grünen dieses thema
blockieren es geht nicht um das 110 neue
gebaut werden nicht wie südkorea japan
frankreich andere länder die massiv
darauf setzen da geht es ja gar nicht
drum wir brauchen jetzt ersatz energie
wir haben die nicht die kernenergie kann
einen wichtigen beitrag leisten für
strom für strompreissenkung für die
frage ob wir verstromung aus gas machen
müssen seit wochen wird das vorschlag
das wissen sie auch lesen da schon wenn
sie jetzt nämlich aus dem akw bereich
aussteigen also wenn sie die drei
laufenden kraftwerke in deutschland
abständen geplant dann müssen sie strom
für zehn millionen haushalte ersetzen
zehnfache preissteigerungen bei strom
wir werden erleben dass viele
normalverdiener echte probleme haben das
alles zu finanzieren
kleine mittelständler können ihre
energie leistung gar nicht mehr bringen
beck hat mir erzählt ann becker vor
wenigen tagen er hatte normalerweise
eine stromrechnung jahr von 20.000 er
rechnet jetzt mit über 200.000 wo
sollten spd enden und deswegen muss doch
politik nach der note entscheiden putin
hat diesen angriff gewagt deutschland
hat eine entscheidung getroffen nämlich
weniger waffen zu liefern dafür beim
energie einen anderen weg zu gehen jetzt
muss aber auch deutschland die deutsche
bundesregierung einen weg finden dass
unser land daran nicht zu leiden die
kosten sind das eine das entsetzt
natürlich alle und ist auch wirklich
eine riesengroße belastung für jeden vor
allem für diejenigen die nicht gut
verdienen allerdings ist ja immer die
frage mit welchen mitteln geht man eben
dagegen vor und wie verständigt man sich
untereinander bei ihnen bleibt eben doch
der eindruck dass die stimmung ein
wesentlicher gradmesser für sie ist sie
hatten einmal über die windräder als
verspargelung der landschaft gesprochen
sie haben beim atommüll endlager gesagt
nicht bei uns in bayern noch bevor
überhaupt eine fachliche prüfung da
stattgefunden hat also sie sehen sich
nicht als jemand der einer stimmung geht
also will ich die aktuelle
bundesregierung anschauen sie streiten
sich im moment über das gas um
langjährig werden beispiel sehen um das
einzuordnen also ich hab den eindruck
wenn jetzt die spd greift dann habe ich
an die grüne jugend greift an habe kann
herr lindner greift dann habe ich an das
war ja gern aber ich bin sogar relativ
freundlich dazu aber das gibt sich
natürlich daraus dass die menschen
besorgt sind also eine politik die nicht
in der lage wäre auf die menschen
einzugehen er wäre ein desaster für eine
demokratie zu handeln diktaturen aber
keine demokratie das wichtig ist dass
mein ziel hat unser ziel war immer die
erneuerbaren voranzubringen noch einmal
in diesem jahr hat bayern den größten
schub an erneuerbaren energien ich hatte
mir endlich mal ein lob dafür zu haben
stattdessen will ich ständig immer das
gegenteil was wohl daran liegt dass sich
insbesondere die grünen gerade mit dem
thema kernkraft zu schwer tue ich hätte
da noch eine kritik für sie gerade beim
ausbau der erneuerung wenn wir mal nach
vorne schauen bayern hat das kraftvolle
ziel ausgegeben schon 20 40 klimaneutral
zu sein und der verein der energie und
wasserwirtschaft in bayern formation
verzahnt dass der verband der energie-
und wasserwirtschaft in bayern der hat
sich einmal die fortschritte angeschaut
und gesagt das ist viel zu langsam was
sie da machen in allen bereichen hinten
sie hinterher ein kollege vom focus hat
sie dazu schon mal gefragt da sind sie
auch ausgewichen und haben auf den bund
verwiesen es geht ja um die frage was
tun sie in bayern für den ausbau der
erneuerbaren warum sind sie dazu langsam
wenn sie die recherche nochmal sehen
dann sehen sie erst einmal dass wir das
einzige land sind das für dieses
ehrgeizige klimaziele auch geld ausgibt
diana geld aus also eine freundin haben
momentan hat die freunde aus baden
württemberg die ich sehr schätze geben
viel weniger dafür aus wir geben pro
jahr eine milliarde ausmacht kein
anderes bundesland
bei den erneuerbaren energien machen wir
mehr als die meisten ich habe es vorhin
schon darauf hingewiesen bei der
wasserkraft beispielsweise schauen sie
wir haben den bund auch nicht verstanden
wir machen beim wind jetzt mehr wir
wollen dort bestimmt am ende über 1000
neue windräder aufstellen klammer auf es
ist nun mal im süden schwerer weil wir
nicht oft haben wir tun aber umgekehrt
mehr bei photovoltaik wir machen
wasserkraft und bioenergie können sie
mir oder kann mir irgendjemand erklären
warum der bund insbesondere können die
wasserkraft erst nicht folgen
grundlastfähig und warum sie die
bioenergie behindern grundlast wer ist
da sind wir stark wird sich dann die
grünen fragen aber jetzt sitzen sie als
csu-vorsitzender und bayerischer
ministerpräsident
ich würde ihn gerne dann noch mal ein
paar zahlen gehen wenn sie sagen sie
investieren so viel dann ist ja die
frage ist das geld gut angelegt denn bei
der wohnraum sanierung waren sie letztes
jahr nur halb so schnell wie es nötig
wäre um ihr selbst gesetztes ziel zu
erreichen gross batteriespeicher nur
zwei prozent des nötigen auch bei
solarkraft mann der sehr stark sind
wie sie selbst erklären müssten sie
jetzt pro woche mindestens 85
fußballfelder neue photovoltaik
installieren das passiert nicht also ist
doch die frage kein turbo bei mit denen
erneuerbaren was hält sie denn auf ich
würde mal sagen wir sind was die
erneuerbaren und die sonne betrifft wie
bayern münchen im fußball wir wollen
natürlich immer noch besser werden aber
die anderen sehen wir da nicht damals
die meisten von uns sind war das seine
energie nicht nur die rücklichter noch
ein beispiel wir haben mehr sonne in
hessen insgesamt erneuerbare hat wir
haben nur mehr wasserkraft als rheinland
pfalz insgesamt erneuert natürlich
wollen wir immer noch besser werden aber
die relation zeigt schon dass wir
ziemlich gut unterwegs sind noch einmal
wir machen noch mehr zwei beispiele wir
machen die agrar photovoltaik wir machen
die renaturierung von mooren seien ganz
riesiges ziel wir pflanzen bäume
millionen von bäume um natürliche co2
speicher voranzubringen und wir
investieren auch in technologie ich
finde es zum beispiel einen schweren
fehler der bundesregierung dass sie
nicht auf beispielsweise synthetische
kraftstoffe ist jetzt dass wir eine der
besten möglichkeiten
gleichzeitig wird die elektro mobilität
behindert verkehr ist ein wichtiger
bereich für die statistik bei
elektromobilität liegt bei 1 auffahren
bleiben wir aber mal bei ihnen es ist ja
der grund unseres gespräches sie selber
sind überzeugt von dem was sie tun es
gibt aber eben viel kritik die kritik
lautet unter anderem sie wechseln zu auf
die positionen und sie kommen eben nicht
hinterher beim erreichen der
selbstgesteckten ziele das hat ist
vielleicht einer der gründe warum es für
sie in bayern momentan auch nicht so gut
läuft wie sie sich das wahrscheinlich
wünschen würden mein kollege mathis
feldhoff war fast mal die aktuelle
situation in 60 sekunden zusammen
noch vor kurzem war dass markus söder
der mann der bäume umarmt der die grünen
als partner für möglich hält der mann
der fast kanzlerkandidat war heute ist
syrer zurück in bayern und nur in bayern
kein volksfest ohne ihn keine rede ohne
beschimpfung von berlin bayern first
markus söder im kampf fand er weiß genau
jetzt geht es ums ganze auch für ihn
sollte er die landtagswahl nächstes jahr
nicht überzeugend gewinnen könnte das
die karriere kosten vor vier jahren bei
seiner ersten wahl als ministerpräsident
fährt söder magere 37 prozent ein das
schlechteste csu ergebnis seit 1950 auch
heute ist es kaum besser knapp 40
prozent in den umfragen und die werte
des csu chefs im sinkflug 54 prozent der
bayern sind unzufrieden mit söders
arbeit und auch intern wächst die kritik
seine kaffeetassen sind oft versteckte
botschaften die neueste spricht aber
eher von verzweiflung oder galgenhumor
herr söder man könnte von außen
betrachtet sagen es läuft nicht gut sie
haben eine landtagswahl vor der brust im
kommenden jahr die augsburger allgemeine
die schaut mit umfragen regelmäßig auf
das stimmungsbild in bayern da war für
sie bei den beliebtheitswerten ihr
persönlicher tiefpunkt im februar
erreicht damals titelte die augsburger
allgemeine nur ein drittel der menschen
in bayern ist mit ministerpräsident
söder zufrieden und insgesamt sind seit
einem dreiviertel jahr nach diesen
umfragen mehr menschen in bayern mit
ihnen als ministerpräsident unzufrieden
als zufrieden was machen sie falsch
ich wunder mich dass sie eine umfrage
von vier nehmen wo drei genau das andere
sagen
v savanne andere bei sat 1 war eine
andere beim bayerischen rundfunk war
eine andere man könnte den eindruck
erwecken sie suchen sich tiere aus ihnen
an der stelle gefällt das ist zulässig
ich nehme alle umfragen ernst aber es
sind ja alles in umfragen wenn von 43
anders sind als eine dann könnte daran
liegen dass möglicherweise das eine
vielleicht aus wirtschaft ist spielt
aber nicht die rolle die rolle spielt ob
wir durch die krise kommen wir haben
bayern bislang gut durch die krise
geführt durch corona sehr gut wir haben
nach den schätzungen des landesamtes für
gesundheit- und 30.000 menschen das
leben gerettet den bayern geht es besser
als allen anderen bundesländern und es
geht sogar so gut dass wir neun
milliarden
länderfinanzausgleich an andere zahlen
und mein einziges ziel ist dass wir auch
die nächste krise gut überstehen und das
waren wir glaube ich auch besser als
viele andere es ist die aufgabe
was uns fehlt ist dagegen ein
ansprechpartner in berlin es stimmt in
dem beitrag der satz stimmt wir fühlen
im moment so ein bisschen zurückhaltung
von berlin gegenüber den bayern
für ihn in bayern und ich bin in bayern
und deswegen sicher über bayern aber ich
jedoch über deutschland denn es leiden
in deutschland millionen von menschen
werden unter dieser energiepolitik dann
auch in der regierung leiten wir machen
vorschläge wie es besser geht die neue
regierung streitet aber eher
untereinander und da liegt im moment
auch der schwerpunkt darauf wir tun
alles was geht sagen ein beispiel allein
deckeln würden wir dann schon ihre
verantwortung freisprechen geld und
pflege gewinnen sieht es zum beispiel
wir haben bei einer als einziges
bundesland ein familien geld dann
bislang schon 750.000 kinder davon
profitiert 250 euro pro monat für ein
kind erstes und zweites lebensjahr oder
für die älteren menschen die von der
bundesregierung schlecht behandelt
wurden beim energie geld haben beim
pflegegeld von 1000 euro nur mal um zu
sagen was dahinter steht das ist schon
ganz okay dass sie damit zufrieden sind
das steht ja außer frage die frage ist
eben reicht das auch für sie
wiedergewählt zu werden und wie sieht es
in ihrer partei aus denn es gibt
tatsächlich einige auftritte
mittlerweile von
aktiven funktionären von
csu-vorsitzenden auf ortsebene die sagen
wir machen das persönlich weil wir eben
mit der führung von markus söder nicht
einverstanden sind weil wir die korona
politik nicht gut fanden weil wir die
den den weg richtung grün auch nicht gut
fanden den war einfach zu vieles dabei
was sie nicht mochten ein paar beispiele
jürgen fraß der csu-vorsitzende von
wunsiedel wollte sich zitat nicht länger
vor das handeln von parteichef markus
söder stellen und in irschen werk ist
der ortsvorsteher gleich mit einem
kollegen ausgetreten weil er gesagt hat
also in diesem kurs da finde ich mich
nicht wieder ist da nicht doch mal zeit
für selbstkritik marien hier machen wir
doch ständig und wir versuchen ständig
ist so gut wie möglich dass man mehr
aber nicht sie geben mir gar nicht die
gelegenheit weil sie sehr gerne so ein
bild zeichnen möglichst maximal negativ
wie es generell
und gerade in berlin ja gerne gerne
gegen bayern gemacht werden wir dann so
schön beieinander sitzen gern mal über
die bayern fest aber zudem auch ihr ex
vorsitzenden
da geht es natürlich im süden auch als
andere dinge schauen sie wir haben der
einzelne orte die haben impfquote von 15
20 natürlich gab es da leute die eine
andere auffassung bei krone hatten aber
am ende haben wir mit dem kurs den wir
gemacht haben nicht zu verantworten hat
130000 menschen das leben gerettet und
sorry leben retten geht vor parteitaktik
das war für mich immer das entscheidende
und da sind geht auch jetzt im moment
durch die krise bringen und schauen sie
allein diese ganzen scharmützel die wir
da gemacht werden anstatt sich jetzt mal
alle am tisch setzen und überlegen was
zusammen zu machen es gibt wieder
gespräche bund länder es gibt wieder
gespräche mit den parteien in berlin die
neue regierung streitet untereinander
ich erlebt selten wir waren echt sehr
offen habe ich war bei uns dann haben
wir alles gemacht was davor gegeben
wurde wir hören seit monaten nichts mehr
davon das ist der neue stil am ende mit
nach hause bringen und ich würde gerne
nochmal ihren ex vorsitzenden erwin
huber zitieren der sagt nämlich die csu
sei in einer dramatischen situation
jetzt wo sie am ruder sind haben sie
nicht manchmal das gefühl dass sie wenn
die umfragewerte nicht stimmen die csu
auch nach unten ziehen nein ich glaube
das gegenteil ist der fall wir leben
halt in anderen zeiten wir haben noch so
eine situation die kein anderer hat
erwin huber weiß wovon er spricht aus
seinen eigenen erfahrungen
wir haben die freien wähler bei uns wir
haben eine sehr gute koalition aber die
neun bis zehn prozent gibt es nirgendwo
anders der großteil davon csu novelle
wenn sie die der aufbrechenden sind wir
bei jeder umfrage nahezu bei den 50 aber
das ist alles so ein spielchen verstehen
sie das für die menschen draußen nicht
sehr relevant ist das im märz endete
darüber entscheidet ob sie
weiterregieren
dass sie zusammen zählen dass sie sagen
gemeinsam haben wir da fast 50 prozent
alleine dann sind die natürlich nicht
nochmal asse eigenen die
landtagspräsidentin die hat ein ziel
ausgegeben für die landtagswahl die sagt
wir streben nach der absoluten mehrheit
er hat sie in der augsburger allgemeinen
gesagt sie sehen ja hier zu sein als sie
das mal gefragt hat oder sie hat es im
herbst gesagt also sie selber oder sie
selber haben in der augsburger
allgemeinen dazu gesagt absolute
mehrheiten gibt es heute in europa
eigentlich nur noch in den ländern die
den umgang mit der medienfreiheit
wesentlich anders in praet ihren als wir
warum setzen sich der andere kraft
verloren ziele als sie also sagen dass
ich glaub ich vor einem jahr gesagt es
ist also wird es jetzt glauben immer
formulieren und also ich finde eine
absolute mehrheit ist schön wenn man
sich vornimmt aber das wirkt doch wie
eine hybris heutzutage und nebenbei
bemerkt die zuschauer jetzt alle
zuschauer stellen sich wahrscheinlich
seit zehn minuten die frage warum redet
nie frau energy ausschließlich über die
landtagswahl nächstes jahr und fragt
nicht was die vorschläge des
ministerpräsident und csu vorsitzende um
diese energie krise zu führen die fragen
sich entsprechend ich rechtlich darauf
hat man doch dass die jetzt darüber
reden was machen wir mit den
energiepreisen da redet sie nicht davon
die haben ganz viele hier ist die
wirklich klar definiert ein zitat von
von einer von einer hoch geschätzten
kollegen vor über einem jahr muss keine
ukraine keine krise gab ich weiß nicht
ob das der mensch so wichtig es für mich
ist wichtig dass wir jetzt diese krise
als deutsches deutsche bevölkerung
überstehen dass wir da gut durchkommen
und ich habe große sorgen ob das klappt
wie es am ende ausgeht was die leute
wirklich glauben dass sehen sie dann bei
der wahl das ist die zeit über heute
hatten herzlichen dank für das gespräch
das war unsere zdf sommerinterview mit
dem csu vorsitzenden und bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten und in der kommenden
woche begrüßte hier an dieser stelle
theo koll dann im gespräch mit dem
bundeskanzler olaf scholz ihnen
herzlichen dank fürs zuschauen und auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]